[Music]
hey guys how are you I was just trying
to go home with a girl from a bar the
other night
and she said I didn't fight you over but
my place is kind of a mess you know I
was like yeah that's not really a
deterrent at 3:30 in the morning yeah
like I'm gonna walk into her apartment
and be like absolutely not you fold
these sheets we could talk but without a
duvet cover it's not gonna happen
okay I was like of course your place is
a mess if you're willing to have sex
with me I'm gonna assume your whole life
is in shambles just random my biological
father on the street I was telling my
friend to bed and he was like it's your
biological father a good person I think
if he were I probably wouldn't refer to
him as my biological father take a
little more ownership over that I look
exactly like him though yeah I show my
friend a picture he was like oh my god
so you guys were separated at birth
we were
it's great to be here guys been watching
porn in my hotel room most of the day so
it's great to be around people again
every porn online now has a link
underneath as a share or post to
Facebook I don't know who's doing that
got your pants around your ankles like
you know needs to see this Gary I fire
off an email my dude I've been thinking
about you so that's the life of a comic
porn and Facebook that's our day every
some Austrian guy added me as a friend
on Facebook he was like you want to join
my hate group I was like who do you hate
he's like blacks Jews everyone I am
Jewish he's not even doing background
checks I'm recruiting that almost
bothered me more than his racism his
lazy recruitment process I was like you
know what I'm just gonna join the hate
group and then drop subtle hints like
while we're committing hate crimes just
walked around hating I'm holding a torch
I'm like dude you know what this flame
reminds me of Hanukkah the miracle of
lights he said yeah I guess you do hate
Jews am I did I hate them I hate them so
much I'm burning up I'm a shavette scene
it's a much he's a car we march on
Saturday I'm like I can't do Saturdays
the sharpest I had a weird racial
situation New York riding the subway I'm
a big Knicks fan I see this guy in the
subway and like hey what do you think
the Knicks this year and he's like why
are you asking me cuz I'm black
it's like you weren't a Knicks Jersey
that's why I asked
he was like yeah cuz it matches my
sneakers cuz like oh that's cuz you're
black
what helps racism good food right you
can't be racist when you're eating good
food it's impossible Jews smoked fish
black people soul food that's why gays
need their own cuisine right be way
harder to be homophobic if you're like
dude you want to order in some gay you'd
be like I don't know that stuff tears my
ass apart just talking new guy told me
gay sex isn't natural because it's not
sex for the purpose of reproduction I
was like no sex I've ever had was for
the purpose of reproduction that sounds
like sex that's gone horribly wrong he
was like it's against nature I was like
I have had sex with my couch so I'm in
no position to judge anyone he's like
yeah but God did not intend a man
another man I'm like I'm pretty sure the
guy who manufactured my couch did not
anticipate me lot of sexual terms named
after baseball right first base second
base if there's grass in the field
play ball I came up with a new and I
call it rained away that's when she's
crying doesn't look good for tonight but
maybe tomorrow right double-header
funny not funny just in line guys to
this I'll give you that
it is give me an example money elevator
the other day I farted and I laugh oh
that's funny okay then the door opened a
hot girl came out I was like that's not
funny
then it was my stop I got off door shut
she's stuck with the fart funny again
she goes to the next floor someone else
gets on hilarious
[Applause]